Sister Kora is AI actually intelligent.
Yes. And she sent shockwave across the
Christian apologetic scene so badly.
Forget the Christian woman. All of them
completely when the video when they saw
the 20 Vs won. Everyone coming out left
right. Damage control. Damage control.
One woman.
Would you push away an orphan? Let's put
it to the test. Allah says in the Quran,
have you seen the one who denies the day
of judgment? Look how Allah connects den
judgment to what? And the one who pushes
away the orphan and doesn't feed the
needy. Pushing the orphan is not
physical push guys. We are sponsoring
orphans with one ummah around the world.
Brothers and sisters whose parents have
died like the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. Subhan Allah. Imagine the
reward like the prophetam said that you
will be like this with me in Jenna
brothers and sisters. Subhan Allah. One
um is a 100 donation policy brothers and
sisters. And I do not get a cut out of
this or a commission out of this. I'm
genuinely asking, brothers and sisters,
because Allah is equating the one who
pushes away the orphan to the one who
denies the day of judgment. You guys are
believers. And in the Quran, Allah talks
about the ones who steal the wealth of
the orphans, they are putting nothing
but fire in their tummy. Brothers and
sisters, the link is there. Sponsor an
orphan even if it's for one month. Enjoy
the video
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Sister Kora, she is somebody that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has blessed with
intellect. I actually call her our
sister in Islam AI and our fellow da
sister. Alhamdulillah AI. What's AI?
She's not artificial intelligence. Okay.
Well, I was going to say just like no
logic's wife cuz artificial art
intelligence has something to offer.
Okay. She has uh uh go's wife is more
like no logic. Okay. He's no logic and
she's Mrs. No logic. Okay. There can be
a caused uncaused uh you know there can
be a triangle with four sides. Absolute
idiot. Sister Kora is AI actually
intelligent. Yes. And she sent shockwave
across the Christian apologetic scene so
badly. Forget the Christian woman. All
of them completely when the video when
they saw the 20 v one. It was David Ward
no logic everyone coming out left right
the damage control damage control one
woman when it was one v2 with no logic's
wife with a dumb argument. Most of the
sisters there I'm not saying all hadith
rejecting this that Allah picked amongst
them a sister who was firm to her dean
to Allah and his messenger did not sugar
coat did not change a religion did not
reject reject hadith may Allah guide
those sisters and honored her wall this
is a sign of honoring her and when she
went one v 20 she knocked everyone out
thus watching and not watching when I
was watching that I was on the floor
like no damn I felt it I Like damn.
Anyways, let's watch this video
inshallah of no logic's wife insulting
Kora. H I wonder why because she got
knocked out so badly that she was
actually sitting right at the back. You
know when you're in a fight and you
don't want them to pick you, so you're
just like hiding the corner like you
know please not me, not me. She was
right at the back. She could have calm
me no baldy. She's right at the back.
Please don't pick me cuz she knows she
was about. She knew everyone's about to
get knocked out and she does not want a
part of that. Look at No logic and his
wife Mrs. No logic. Okay. Triangle with
four sides. Absolute Okay. Let's
watch it for ourself inshallah. Uh and
then dissect. So this is the first clip.
Uh let's go.
>> Like a that Kora girl, she's a weirdo.
Like talk about weird. And I was like,
huh? Like what did I do to you? Apart
from debate you.
>> I already wasn't a big fan just because
of her demeanor and how she carries
herself.
>> But man, talk about like a weirdo.
Girl, let me tell you something about
her. That's a evilspirited lady. That's
a evilspirited lady for real. Like every
everybody that talk like the lady with
the green and the Asian lady, my my
intuition, my spirit, I got good energy
for them.
>> Those were the two people that I loved
speaking with the most.
>> I love speaking with them.
>> See, so we could tell that those are
good. Well, I could say I feel like good
spirited people. Them other people, they
still need help. You could tell they
still on their journey.
>> Exactly. So, that is I don't know if
that's another fellow Christian sister
or Muslim sister that you're speaking
to, but you can clearly see the agenda.
No logic and his wife. Do you really
believe they believe in Christ? They
know they've been knocked out
intellectually. They're holding on cuz
they believe in this Christ. Okay, let's
go to the video now. Her and her uh
husband. Okay, you know who's uh you
know, look at me. He's there like a
little mosquito. I believe he has
inferiority complex. believe no no no
logic just funding a lifestyle for her
to stay with her in and you're going to
see you're going to see how Allah
exposes them because they are evil
spirited you're going to see how in time
how Allah will expose their reality but
let's get into it inshallah
>> right after my episode finished filming
we filmed her episode so she actually
had backed out and Kora was one of the
Muslims on my episode right after my
episode finished filming we filmed her
episode so she actually has a 1V I think
she had 19 or 18 Christians and
>> that got the idol it It was not It's not
one v 20 cuz she knocked out 20. Look,
she didn't knock out 20 of us. And she
knocked out I think it was 19 or 18 of
us. You don't get to fight. Yo, I heard
you all got knocked out. Nah, no, bro.
It wasn't all of us. It was It was 18
19. I heard it was 20. No, it was 19.
>> I was on her episode as well. So, it was
a long day for me. I was there from like
literally all day filming those episodes
back toback.
>> Wow, that's crazy. Now, did
>> did you hear that? It was It was a long
day for me. You know, I was doing back
toback, you know. I did a performer, you
know, where somebody lo Yeah. You know,
it was just it was just a hard day, man.
You know, the weather, man. I broke my
back spinal. Yes. No. Cora destroyed
you. And not only that, she even admits,
Nich admits with her own mouth. Nikki's
wife. Yeah. Admits that Cora was a bit
too much.
>> Want to talk about that or do you want
to get into that after we do the review?
>> It's up to you. I think that there's
definitely been some weird behavior.
Now, of course, I've seen my husband and
a few others, Jai, Don, a few life
interact with Kora, and I already wasn't
a big fan just because of her demeanor
and how she carries herself. But man,
>> with all due respect, if we go to the
comment section, how she carries
herself, it's applauded even by
non-Muslims. We're going to go into the
comment section. People are flocking to
Islam saying after I watch accepted
Islam. Yes. Bear so many comments. So
what do you mean her demeanor? What do
we see? We see wretched behavior from
you. With all due respect, with your
attitude, your demeanor, the way even
others are seeing your evil energy with
sister Kora, without being biased, she
carried herself honorably.
>> Talk about like a weirdo. I know she's
young, so I try to give her grace for
that. But she is literally one of those
people that will be in front of you face
to face and have a completely different
energy. And then after like after we all
got done filming, she was on TikTok
later that night just lying.
>> What do you mean? Why are you calling
her a weirdo? I don't understand. What's
why you call what kind of statement? Oh,
he's he's stupid. Okay. Why? No, he's
just stupid. Why? It just is. What's Why
is she weird? Okay, tell us that she
done something weird. Yes. If and by
weird you mean she demolished you guys
intellectually. Oh, if you think that
she's weird, then I will call her the
biggest weirdo. If that's your
definition of being weird, call me a
weirdo. I'm a weirdo.
>> Saying I ran from her, that I quit
before the episode was over, that I
didn't pick her for my one-on-one, all
this stuff, right? Well, I did my
episode, so I didn't pick her for my
one-on-one cuz I knew she was going to
have her episode next and I was going to
be on it.
>> So, you admit you did not pick her for
oneonone and we don't blame you. Look,
look, look. Nobody blames you. Let's
just talk. Let me be honest with you.
Nobody that's watching this in the
Muslim, non-Muslim, Christian community
blames you did not want a one-on-one.
Blames no one. Like, we don't blame you.
>> And that she I figured she was probably
going to pick me for her one-on-one. So,
>> not what I would assume here is because
you're Lady Logic. You're God Logic's
wife.
>> God Logic is the man that they want.
They're all coming at God Logic. So,
this would be Cora's perfect opportunity
to get God Logic's wife one-on-one and
humiliate her. But and and that's what
happened, right?
>> Oh, not at all. You know, she didn't
pick me for her um one-on-one.
>> What?
>> Well, hold on. Hold on. Hold on a
second. You just admitted you did not
pick her. You did not pick her. Okay. As
simple as that. And with all due
respect, when you say it's like saying
Mike Tyson did not pick me, uh, etc.
What did you have to offer? She
annihilated all of them women who were
much more well-versed than you. She
roasted. So, what was you going to bring
to the table when you admitted that you
did not pick her?
>> Oh, yeah. No, we just sneaking on by
that one.
>> Ain't no way.
>> Did you just say that Cora, the one that
come there to try to destroy God Logic's
wife, did not even choose to have the
one-on-one with her?
>> No, she didn't. And it's so funny
because that's why I didn't pick her for
mine. I was like, for one thing, um, she
was acting like she didn't bring
anything good on my episode. So, I was
like, she's probably going to bring me
something dumb on mine. So, I'll pick
someone else for mine. She'll pick me
for hers and I'll talk to her then. I
thought it was going to be that simple.
I didn't want to talk to her. I didn't
want to have two one-on- ones with her
and do her episode and she just did
mine. That's a little too much Kora for
me.
>> I agree. Like,
>> but I knew she was going to pick me
>> in that situation.
>> Oh, damn. I'm sure it is a little too
much Cora for you. I'm sure it is. I'm
very sure it is. Mrs. No logic
>> because the girl that you did have the
one-on-one with, you already had a
discussion the last time you were on
doing the four verse four. She was there
during that time, too, wasn't she?
>> No, that was a different M Lima. That
was Kadija. And um Kadija didn't come to
play around. I don't know if we'll get
to the part where I was talking to her,
but um I think she definitely came on a
mission to redeem herself from the last
episode. Unfortunately, she just ended
up giving me a lob for a powerful moment
in my episode that I really was proud
of. So,
>> yeah, she's probably You know what
happened is she probably got back and
after all the reviews about you verse,
well, the four of you, not just you, of
course. The other three Christian women
did their thing, too. Uh but the
Christian women just destroyed the
Muslim women and almost every review uh
said the same thing. So, I think they
got a lot of backlash last even at their
own mosque. And the only thing that they
got backlash was because uh if they did
that is is because of them rejecting
hadith and trying to scrot the religion.
That's the only thing. Be true to your
cause. That was the only thing. Not that
anyone destroyed anyone because they
were insecure and an inferiority
complex. Oh, I don't believe in that
hadith. Oh, Aisha was 18 or this that
got humiliated. Sister Kora didn't come
with that energy. That's why when sister
Kora accepted offended had came and even
demolished knowledge's wife in both
episodes. You can clearly see subhan
Allah that Allah gave her. Look at we're
going to read the comment section in a
minute, but let's carry on. Of this uh
uh this woman, Subhan Allah, the lies
that she spread spread in.
>> Yeah, if you remember, she was the one
who um hadn't read any. She admitted she
had never read it and so she apologized
for saying it was corrupted the previous
scriptures. That was Kada. So, she was
on my previous episode. The one that I
did end up doing my one-on-one with was
because I kind of saw that open door to
reach her. And so, I didn't want to
waste my time on Kora when I saw
potential for someone who might be open
to Christ. And that swayed my decision
more.
>> Yes. You didn't want to mess with Kora
because you knew Kora would knock you
out in intellectually. So you thought,
let me go to someone that's not that
versed in their scripture and might be
open to Christ. So it's very interesting
that they go for people who are not
well-versed and be open to Christ
because they know nobody from the
outside will look at Christianity and be
like that makes sense. Do you know how
many people thousands of people millions
around the world come to Islam and we
ask them Christians what was the one
thing? Trinity. Trinity. Trinity.
Trinity. Trinity. How could the most
fundamental belief system that you guys
believe you have is the reason people
leave the Islam? How many people when
you see these so-called ex-Muslims who
leave? Do they come and say, "Oh, Allah
the didn't make one sense to me." No,
it's more inferiority complex of, "Oh,
prophet's marriage to Aisha. I didn't
like that." Okay, so you want to follow
religion based on your likings. Okay,
then uh you go to the Bible, rape, rape
her and pay for the shelves to the dad.
Well, and and you already were under the
understanding, and I probably would have
figured it too, that Cora was going to
choose you so that she could try to have
that one-on-one where she could push you
on.
>> She said she wanted it so bad
>> and that would have been her topic that
she would have been able to push you on
and she was still too much of a And now,
if they're saying that you ran, how's
that not Kora running from you? Like,
>> I don't know. That's
>> I love the damage control. I love the
damage control of trying. Let's twist it
a bit here and there, etc. Kora ran from
you. Sister Cora, may Allah bless,
preserve you, and protect you.
Alhamdulillah. uh you know me and my
wife we saw your videos and we like I'll
be honest you with you we was making dua
for you wallah me and my wife it's it's
so amazing and refreshing and I've
mentioned this to you and I ask Allah I
don't want to overpraise you I don't
want to praise you please I would my as
my sister in Islam I'll tell you my dear
sister you're a public figure as your
brother in the dow it's been for 14
years alhamdulillah okay I don't know
how young you might be even be young
enough to be my daughter um is this
don't miss your morning in evenar do not
miss your morning you're a public figure
the unseen is far more dangerous than
anything I've spoken to you on the DMs
as well And we have something planned
with the sister inshallah. May Allah
bless and preserve her uh which we will
talk about later. Um do you
alhamdulillah your knowledge is sharp.
May Allah bless you. Preserve you always
remember Allah subhanaa tala. Always
praise Allahh. May Allah protect you
from the fna of fame, the fna of money,
the fitna of other things, whatever it
is. Inshallah these are struggles that
come to all of us. Subhan Allah. My dear
sister, may Allah bless you. We as your
brothers are always here to defend you
against these cowards. Alhamdulillah.
Carry on doing what you're doing.
Alhamdulillah. It is a breath of fresh
air to know that there is a Muslim woman
who observes hijab is proud of her
religion is happy with Allahh and his
messenger. All the hadith are authentic
and she's not based based on her beauty
and this and that. She has more to offer
than sadly influencers who are too busy
dressing inappropriately. If they have a
journey that's fine accept that. But
trying to misguide people uh reject
hadith coffee statements etc. All
they're known is about their eyelashes,
makeup, lipstick or that etc. Whereas
we've got a sister who is alhamdulillah
offering something which is her mind,
not her body, not her lips, not her uh
eyelashes or whatever it is for that
matter. So it's a breath of fresh air to
mention this because it's h I'm so
sorry. We are in the dow scene been
dying to have sisters like you who can
come to the scene and support in saying
that the sister agrees with everything I
say and neither it might be a time that
I don't agree with everything she says.
The key is not that the key is unity on
h but let's just finish this in we're
going to go to the comment section.
>> Just how Muslim mental gymnastics work.
>> All right. So
>> what a good point. It's
look like a witch, man. May Allah subh
guide you to Islam
>> since we need to get into this. We need
to get into this here. So we have the
>> I'm not going to lie. I just want to
zoom into her face. Yeah, guys. She
knows. You know this moment here. I just
want to take a screenshot of this here.
Okay. You can see no logic there. She
knows. No logic knows what happened that
day. Yeah. He knows it was a is it was
intellectual massacre. Okay. She knows.
Look at her face. She knows that, man.
Kora smashed her so bad. She's like,
"Damn, I wish I was not there." You
know, she's like, you can see from her
face. Subhan Allah. Now, let's go to the
comment section. Yes. I'm going to go to
the comment section. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
This is one V20. Smash the other one.
Okay. Over 1.2 million. And let me tell
you something. This got maybe 100
million views. Platforms, Instagram, you
name it. It was popping. It's like the
entire dunya knows about it.
Alhamdulillah. And that's what Allah
does. Allah will honor somebody who
doesn't sugarcoat their religion, who
doesn't come and reject hadith and this
and that, who takes time out and studies
their faith and is sure this is the
byproduct of what it looks like and
Allah subhana wa tala will honor people
with this dean like said if you look for
honor other ways apart from Allah's dean
Allah will humiliate you. This is the
religion Islam that has given honor to
the believers. And believe me, wahi, if
you stick to it and hold firm to it,
subhan Allah, Allah will honor you. And
this is what I believe. Sister Kora,
Allah made her outshine all of them
intellectually. Look at what the comment
section was saying. Yes. Okay. Quality
of these quantity. Alhamdulillah. I
became Muslim because of this sister.
Alhamdulillah. It's not the eyes that
are blind, but it's the heart. Kora is
19 years old. Wow. She is young enough
to be my daughter. Yes, she's insane.
May Allah bless her. Asking Kora not to
interrupt and then immediately
interrupting her sums everything in this
debate. Thank you. Her memory is so
sharp. The way she remembers each of the
points and responds to every single one
and remembers them in the future for
reference. Whoa. There you go.
19-year-old Muslim woman that has so
much knowledge. May Allah protect,
increase, and uh preserve her. They
tried to mock her, but they fell on
their heads. Just so you all know, Kora
is 19. 19. And she did this brilliantly
and knows this. Mashallah. Should I be
honest with you so much that subhan
Allah I've seen other influences sisters
who are like you know what yo hats off
hats off and Muslim women should be
known not by their looks their body
parts etc by what's in here to serve the
dean that comes from the heart yes
submitting to Allah and his messenger in
the heart fully and then intellectually
massacring alhamdulillah and inviting
people to Islam brothers and sisters may
Allah bless and preserve it inshallah
and subhan allah this the reason why
Look, we at people that come to Islam,
we teach them how to pray salah. Salah
Pro. Alhamdulillah, sisters, download
the app. It's for free. And we have
Salah Pro math. If you are a new Muslim
or you don't know how to pray Salah,
you're a Muslim, you don't know how to
pray Salah, download the Salah Pro app
and order your free guided prayer.
Inshallah. Alhamdulillah. And I believe
something this project that we do is
something I believe Sister Kora would
love to support. Inshallah. And
inshallah. If she does come to London,
we would love to give her the feedback
for her to see this guided mat that
we're printing 100,000 in Italian,
German, French, Spanish, Japanese, and
English, and even for kids.
Alhamdulillah, I believe every sister in
the Dawa scene or D brother should get
this inshallah sent out or encourage
people accept Islam to download it for
absolutely
free. Not a single penny. Alhamdulillah,
brother sisters, that's all I wanted to
say. May Allah bless and preserve you
guys. Sister Kora, may Allah protect
you. May Allah uh um aid you and
increase your knowledge to serve his
dean. Uh and that's all I have to say
inshallah. I don't want to overprace.
I'm sure she's a human being. She will
make mistakes. She will be prone to make
mistakes. Uh that's alhamdulillah. We
all are sinners in different ways and we
make mistakes. Yeah, that's it. Till
next time.